this is what it looks like to be a World
Cup winner in Argentina
video captured by midfielder Rodrigo de
Paul from the team Bus shows the huge
crowds that turned up in the middle of
the night to Welcome Home the country's
Victorious footballers
[Applause]
led by Captain Lionel Messi the
Champions had disembarked their flight
at around 3 A.M he'd waited so long to
get his hands on the trophy Argentina's
Talisman wasn't letting it go even
taking it to bed for a well-earned rest
as their open top bus inched its way
through the crowds for some like 12 year
old Lucia it was all too much
meanwhile on the other side of the world
thousands turned out in Paris to Welcome
Home the defeated finalists
disappointment but Pride too in a French
team that was just edged out in one of
the greatest World Cup finals of all
time
I'm here to support the players I'm here
to cheer them up that they played really
well and we are all very proud of them
as a beautiful Summer's Day dawned in
Argentina an enormous crowd gathered at
the obelisk in Buenos Aires president
Alberto Fernandez declared today a
national holiday so the country could
enjoy the celebrations and the nation
seemed happy to oblige
every vantage point is being snapped up
as thousands wait for the arrival of the
team bus and the World Cup trophy in the
center of the capital for one of the
largest parties in Argentina's history
Stephen Murphy Sky News